you and I were just talking about math
singer and what a fun success it has
been it's awesome I'm really happy for
Jenny for the show you know she's been
very selective workwise since we started
dating and co-parenting and getting
married and she's really a homebody you
know she really wants to be home and to
take care of the family and to you know
I I have so many jobs and so much going
on it's you know one of us kind of had
to hold down the fort and when this came
along she wasn't sure if it was
something she should do and we decided
as a couple you know go for it you've
been staying home and like you know
giving so much time to the family you
know go let me stay home and watch the
kids you go to work and you go do your
thing and for it to be such a success
after she's been so selective I'm just
I'm really happy for her and and proud
of her it's it's a fun show and it was a
risk you know you never know with a show
like that how it's gonna go but I felt
confident that it was something the
country really needed you know just
turning the singing competition shows
upside down in a way that really allows
us to just escape and in occupy our
minds with something else besides all
the stuff that we have to think about
everyday you know I think it's the
perfect show at the perfect time well
I'm gonna ask you something a little
risky okay but I'm confident you might
be game we just so happen to have one of
the masked singer masks here today and
hi I'm gonna be seeing your lovely wife
very soon and I was wondering if you
wanted to give a little song or a little
disguise and we're gonna see if she can
guess that it is her own hubby behind a
mask
oh my god do you know I can't
technically put this on legally that
could be a clue or a giveaway but right
now I'm trending second or third in who
is the rabbit on mass singer and in the
public polls it's between myself Joey
Fatone and Joey McIntyre
and I think JC Chaussee from NSYNC is
fourth place right now so people
actually think that you're audited all
right everyone thinks I'm the rabbit I
think this is a trick you're trying to
get me to expose you yeah I'm gonna get
in trouble
let's see them let's see if it matches
up hold on the rabbit does like a thing
it goes like a thing and he has a
straitjacket on right yeah let's see if
you can disguise your voice a little bit
and we'll give a little message to your
wife how do they do
okay what's the voice they do hold on I
know I act like a rabbit in the bedroom
too so hopefully you'll know who this is
very scary people yes very scary title
yes what can you reveal about this very
scary new show I think the the best
thing that I could possibly reveal about
serial killers and mass killers who are
household names is the depths with which
we're gonna investigate them and revisit
these cases a lot of people don't know
some of them were never solved some of
the bad guys were never caught and with
this show you know it's sort of
interesting because now with DNA
technology you hear about so many cases
being overturned from the past or people
being caught after all these years you
know as technology grows and expands it
allows the police to investigate
differently but now when you do a show
with HLN and they have all this archival
footage and news stories and stuff we're
actually revisiting and reinvestigating
the stories much like in a parallel with
the with the law enforcement so it's
really fascinating to revisit it and the
country just people just love crime
shows they love it how much of a true
crime junkie are you and Jenny
we are totally addicted to Forensic
Files which when they call from HLN
saying we have a show for you on HLN I
was like what is it gonna come on after
Forensic Files ah man literally Forensic
Files started our binge watching behave
as a couple and you know I try to like I
host very scary people I tried to get
somewhere between Bill Kurtis and Rod
Serling you know in my in my
presentations you know every now and
again I'd lean a little more rod serling
and just be a little weird with it and
then I'd have to go Bill Curtis and be a
little more mysterious with it you know
but I think I found my voice